non
[Musique]
il l'histoire des sciences fourmille de
polémiques en tous genres celle dont
nous allons parler ici est encore
fraîche et concerne la trisomie 21
si elle résonne encore aujourd'hui cette
controverse prend racine il y a plus de
60 ans à paris
laon 1958 marque un tournant dans
l'histoire de la médecine nous sommes en
france à l'hôpital trousseau dans le 12e
arrondissement de paris un jeune médecin
à l'oeil rieur et pencher sur un
microscope il compte les chromosomes
contenus dans le noyau d'une cellule
humaine et s'apprête à faire une
découverte capitale la voici racontait
dans sa biographie jérôme lejeune la
liberté du savant
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
la médecine le docteur jérôme lejeune
parvient à identifier un chromosome en
trop ce chromosome s'ajoute ici à la
plus petite paire dans le carnet
danalyse que jérôme a commencé le 10
juillet 1957 et où il consignait à la
main minutieusement les caryotype obtenu
c'est à dire la carte des chromosomes
placé par paire il est créé à la 9e
ligne le 22 mai 1958 jean françois r 3
mois mongolien un chromosome
surnuméraire
après avoir répliqué l'expérience sur 3
puis 9 autres patients trisomique
l'hypothèse semble confirmer les
trisomiques que l'on appelait mongolien
à l'époque possède bel et bien un
chromosome surnuméraire dans leur
caryotype avec ses collaborateurs il
écrit plusieurs publications l'une
d'elles concluant nous pensons pouvoir
affirmer que le mongolisme est une
maladie chromosomique la première à être
démontrée définitivement dans notre
espèce
le mongolisme et rebaptisé prison me 21
la nouvelle fait le tour du monde grâce
aux publications scientifiques et aux
présentations de jérôme lejeune lors de
congrès cette découverte majeure ouvre
la voie à un nouveau champ de recherche
en génétique humaine et entraîne la mise
en place du diagnostic prénatal
sauf que en fait il semblerait que
l'histoire ne se soit pas tout à fait
dérouler comme cela
reprenons tout commence deux ans plus
tôt en août 1956 à copenhague lors du
premier congrès international de
génétique de chercheurs annoncent que le
nombre de chromosomes chez l'humain et
de 46 et non de 48 comme on le pensait
jusqu alors assiste à ce colloque le
professeur turpin chef de service à
l'hôpital trousseau et qui travaille sur
ce qu'on appelle à l'époque le
mongolisme
c'était quelque chose de très typé tous
les enfants se ressembler
donc il avait cherché
par rapport au maire si elle est maire
avait des pathologies particulières
la seule chose qu'ils avaient été
reconnus c'est que les femmes étaient
souvent plus âgés que d'habitude autour
de la quarantaine c'était plus fréquent
de voir des mères d'enfants trisomiques
que des femmes de 20 ans quoi pour
tenter de trouver l'origine du
mongolisme le professeur turpin étudient
notamment les empreintes digitales et
les lignes de la main des patients avec
un chercheur de son équipe le docteur le
jeune mais ce n'est pas sa seule piste
france on étudiait la patrie il y avait
des trucs un peu bizarres qui est
soupçonné qu'il était possible que je
sois leur fine chromosomiques
tomber c'était donc dans le prix du
repas mais à l'époque les techniques ne
permettait pas de compter les
chromosomes dans le noyau d'une cellule
jusqu'à l'arrivée d'une certaine marque
gauthier dans le service chef de
clinique fraîchement rentré des états
unis où elle avait obtenu une bourse
d'un an à l'université d'harvard de
l'histoire les simples martin gauthier
va aux états unis en 55 sur les
suggestions du professeur robert debré
vivant en principe pour apprendre la
cardiologie et aux états unis on me vais
un jour demander si par hasard je
pouvais pas rendre service à la
technicienne et où étaient enceintes ou
des partis en vacances qu'il fallait que
je la remplace
pour faire des cultures cellulaires
c'est comme ça que j'ai appris un peu
bêtement sur leurs tirs sur le temps et
elle revient des états unis en sachant
cultiver des cellules et
étaler le noyau des cellules et les
colorés pour y
observer le nombre de chromosomes une
compétence qu'elle va utiliser au sein
de son nouveau laboratoire celui du
professeur turpin j'avais demandé à ma
future d'un flux edi puisque maintenant
on sait que l'espèce humaine à 46
chromosomes si vous voulez je vais me
proposer de vous faire des cultures
cellulaires et il m'a regardé en disant
de toute façon personne ne se faire les
cultures cellulaires en france je lui
dis c'est possible je m'engage à le
faire elle conditions comme donniez à
locale et justement tu repasses se
propose me dit d'accord alors tout le
monde a regardé indiqué son petit fils à
elle arrive des états unis et elle veut
dire que elle va faire des cultures
cellulaires alors que personne entrer en
ce sens et elle faisant la culture
cellulaire qui découvre qu'il ya des
cellules qu'ils ont
un effectif chromosomiques inhabituels
ou la minute papillon on va trop vite
d'abord il a fallu que marthe gauthier
montrent le premier laboratoire de
culture cellulaire en france avec les
moyens de l'époque et parfois même sur
ses propres deniers pour compter ses
précieux chromosomes il lui fallait bien
évidemment des tissus de patients
trisomique et non trisomique ce qui
n'était pas facile à obtenir mais ce
n'est pas tout il lui fallait aussi des
ingrédients un peu particulier des oeufs
embryonnés du sérum humain qu'elle
prélève sur elle-même et du plasma de
coke elle va donc chercher un coq dans
la ferme de ses parents il a dormi
groupe ii doit on encore que dans la
dent may 4 chevaux lendemain matin très
inquiète je savoir s'il a des choix à
faire cocorico ou pas
et personne ne me l'avait volé et j'ai
eu mon copte est arrivé est trop sont
bons mais arrivé à tours c'est une
affaire mais après pour manger alors
j'avais une des mes infirmières que
j'avais bien qui habitait là bas et je
lui dis est ce que vous voulez bien
prendre mon comme dans votre jardin elle
m'a dit oui très volontiers pour la
technique et j'ai vu alors tout le monde
voulait starace de coqs et s'est vu
donner les bercail pommes de terre léger
plus cher et c'est mon corps qui était
très heureux le coq devient la star du
service est l'emblème de marthe tous les
ingrédients sont à présent réunies à
l'hôpital trousseau les expériences
peuvent commencer assisté de deux
techniciennes de laboratoire madame
massé et madame cavani mart observe le
caryotype de cellules témoins et de
cellules prélevées sur des enfants dits
mongolien et dans ce laboratoire il ya
un jeune chercheur qui est à monsieur le
jeune qui vient et qui participe à
certaines des expériences une fois les
préparations faites martelé passe au
microscope et découvre une chose pour le
moins déroutante margot teva observé
un chromosome surnuméraire dans les
cellules cultivées à partir des enfants
mongolie
mais il lui manque une chose essentielle
pour pouvoir s'assurer de sa découverte
un microscope capable de réaliser des
photographies on peut compter avec les
yeux champel de photos mais on ne peut
jamais dire aux gens que
46 est tout à fait certain certains
parce que les chromosomes si vous voulez
regarder des photos ils sont gros comme
ça pas gros et on peut se tromper très
bien et tandis qu'on ne s'y trompe pas
quand la photo est sur papier
des ciseaux on le découpe dans l'école
pour qu'il soit que les pères soient
bien à parier et pour savoir combien il
y en a son collègue de laboratoire
jérôme lejeune lui propose alors
d'emporter les lames et de les faire
photographier dans un laboratoire danois
où il se rend peu après marthe accepte
je lui donne mes lames et et ne confirme
que j'ai tout à fait raison que je vais
toujours compter ce qui était vrai mais
est bien entendu ne les rend pas tout de
suite
jérôme lejeune présente la découverte
lors du congrès de génétique à montréal
et enchaîne les conférences en amérique
du nord son chef le professeur turpin
lui a donné pour consigne de défendre la
position de la génétique française en
présentant la découverte il aurait omis
de citer le nom de marc gauthier et on
retiendra comme le nom de celui qui a
présenté dans les congrès mais les
péripéties ne font que commencer
ces travaux vont donner lieu quelque
temps plus tard à une publication dans
les comptes rendus de l'académie des
sciences et je m'aperçois que je ne suis
pas la première signée terre alors que
c'est moi qui est elle travaille alors à
ce moment là bonjour poule quand je
parle de ma voiture et je m'en vais
et je me dis ça y est je suis eu parce
que ça s'appelle maintenant
ça s'appelle le jeune gauthier turin
[Musique]
en sciences de la vie l'ordre des
auteurs qui signent une publication est
cruciale il traduit l'importance de leur
contribution à l'étude voici ce qu'en
dit l'alliance nationale pour les
sciences de la vie et de la santé les
positions dont la signification sur les
plus claires sont celles de premier et
de dernier auteur le premier auteur
étant celui dont la contribution
opérationnelle a été la plus importante
souvent un chercheur junior le dernier
auteur étant un chercheur senior qui l'a
conseillé et a guidé le projet les
autres auteurs vont au milieu rangés par
ordre décroissant selon leur
contribution aux travaux de recherche
dans ce contexte il peut paraître
étonnant que marc gauthier est était la
deuxième auteur de l'étude annonçant la
découverte de la trisomie 21
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
si elle avait découvert
[Musique]
la trisomie 21 aujourd'hui elle serait
la première signataire à condition
d'avoir fait elle même la publication
visiblement ce n'est pas elle qui a fait
la première publication elle a été au
sein d'une équipe voilà donc c'est comme
ça que le dérapage s'est construit
c'est malheureusement simple donc le
jeune c'est turpin qui dure près ça
parce qu'il voulait que parce que le jeu
ne vais travailler avec lui dont les sur
les dépôts mme des enfants mongolien et
il avait travaillé sur cette question
donc moi j'ai effectivement je ne vais
pas le travailler sur cette question
mais j'avais travaillé sur celle qui
avait donné plus de résultats et j'ai
trouvé tout à fait 1 2 je suis parti
on est allé se promener histoire de dire
c'est pas possible de vivre avec dans
cet univers
et je le dois dire que mes futurs pas et
bien entendu à mes yeux toujours
coupable de me voir me ans le jeune
gauthier turpin et je dois ajouter que
gauthier s'était il avait mis mari hoon
mortes et gauthier avait 1 h et vous
savez bien vous on n'est pas un achat
goûter et surtout pour une publication
parce que pubmed tu connais pubmed ces
faits marc gauthier avec anna on en
longue passe pas la version de jérôme
lejeune est radicalement différente de
celle ci dans la biographie jérôme
lejeune la liberté du savant apparel
extraits d'une lettre écrite par le
docteur le jeune en 1984 à l'historien
des sciences daniel cowes il lui écrit
en fait turpin ne m'a pas du tout
conseillé de publier les données quand
je lui ai proposé de cosigner il a
hésité parce qu'il n'avait jamais
regardé les chromosomes et il a dit bon
je pense que je vais signer juste parce
que en l'état actuel de l'ignorance
personne ne nous cherchera querelles si
ce n'est pas vrai de plus au moment de
la publication marteau gauthier était en
congé et quand elle est rentrée elle m'a
dit que j'avais pris une liberté
excessive à mettre son nom en deuxième
position sur une publication par
laquelle elle n'était pas convaincu ses
souvenirs ne doivent absolument pas être
mentionné dans un document imprimé ce
serait manquer grandement de délicatesse
envers turpin et marthe gauthier et je
détesterais de telles critiques
tous les chercheurs de l'époque
qui ont pu être contactés ou qui ont
discuté savent qui a fait le travail et
dans quelles conditions et avec les
contributions de chacun étant pédiatre
j'ai connu martin gauthier dans son
activité professionnelle tout simplement
j'ai connu assemble de personnes de
l'époque et donc je me souviens très
bien que quand j'étais interne marc
gauthier intervenait dans des les staffs
du service et que le chef de service la
présentait comme la découvreuse de la
trisomie 21
alors c'est aussi simple que ça dans le
milieu pédiatrique s'étaient connus
voilà on savait
saisie sur cette question en 2014 le
comité d'éthique de l'inserm présidé par
hervé chneiweiss souligne néanmoins le
rôle que le jeune à jouer dans la mise
en valeur de ces travaux il est
indéniable que
jérôme lejeune a été partie prenante de
ce travail qu'il a été à l'évidence un
médiateur
de premier plan puisqu'il est le premier
à avoir
communiqué à la découverte il l'est
probablement
celui qui en rentrant a dû dire nous
devons rapidement publier notre
découverte sinon d'autres en particulier
des britanniques étaient aussi sur la
piste et donc il aurait pu se faire
entre guillemets ce coupé malgré cela le
message principal de l'avis du comité
d'éthique de l'inserm et le suivant vu
le contexte à l'époque de la découverte
du chromosome surnuméraire la part de
jérôme lejeune dans celle ci a peu de
chance d'avoir été prépondérante à moins
de ne pas porter crédit à la formation
des personnes ici martin gauthier dans
l'acquisition d'une expertise ici la
culture cellulaire a fortiori quand
associé à un séjour hors de france ici
aux etats unis
la découverte de la trisomie n'ayant pu
être fait sans les contributions
essentielles de raymond turpin et marthe
gauthier il est regrettable que leur nom
n'est pas été systématiquement associé à
cette découverte tant dans la
communication que dans l'attribution de
divers honneurs
[Musique]
après la publication de l'étude
annonçant la découverte et les premières
communications de lejeune au nom du
laboratoire les relations se tendent au
sein de l'équipe comme en témoigne
simone chez le jeune craintes à l'époque
quand j'allais dans ce labo là je suis
allé pour des raisons bien précises je
n'avais pas des changes particulier quoi
avec avec elle à l'époque mais je
sentais qu'il y avait quand même un
malaise à ce moment là je me suis plus
tourné vers d'autres domaines que
j'étudiais et que je ne renie pas ce
sont éventuellement la cardiologie
infantile une donnée
d'endroits préféré souhaitant travailler
et même une blanche une malade mon voit
régulièrement un bouquet de fleurs
marthe gauthier part donc dans un
service de cardiologie infantile et y
réalise une brillante carrière
raymond turpin part à la retraite quant
à jérôme lejeune ils continuent les
recherches sur la trisomie 21 et
d'autres maladies génétiques il se
présentera dès lors sur la scène
scientifique internationale comme le
découvreur de la première trisomie
humaine une version reprise est cultivée
par la fondation qu'il a laissé derrière
lui la fondation jérôme lejeune et
surtout ensuite vu jérôme lejeune qui
accueillait les gens et qu'ils
accueillaient avec beaucoup de d'amitié
de
de sympathie
au fur et à mesure
pour des raisons qui
que nous n'avons pas à juger le nom des
personnes ayant réellement participer au
travail et qui sans les les découvreurs
donc mart qui a fait le travail
expérimental permettant de découvrir le
chromosome surnuméraire
raymond turpin qui est à l'origine du
projet de recherche
vont faire une jambe disparaître au
profit d'un seul découvreurs je crois
que très vite on a dit que jérôme
lejeune avait découvert un trésor une
anomalie chromosomique chez les enfants
mongolien je pense mais je sais
difficile de la postériorité
reconstituer ça parce que ça s'est fait
petit à petit ce qui a été après
beaucoup plus frappant c'est que la
fondation lejeune sait plus comment ça
s'appelait au début
publier des journaux en dix ans le
professeur qui a découvert la trisomie
21 à tel point que même les enfants
turpin ont trouvé que c'était
insupportable et ont protesté parce que
leur père avait été gommée de l'histoire
aussi alors qu'il avait quand même passé
des dizaines d'années a cherché à
comprendre en 1996 l'avocate des
héritiers du professeur turpin a fait
parvenir à la fondation jérôme lejeune
un pli recommandé avec accusé de
réception dans lequel elle lui a demandé
de respecter le droit de leurs pairs à
l'aco paternité de la découverte de la
trisomie 21
livre manuel de médecine jusqu'à peu la
découverte et est généralement attribué
au professeur lejeune ce qui est encore
le cas dans certains documents comme sa
biographie cité en introduction sa page
wikipédia ou encore le site de la
fondation lejeune
tout le monde s'en foutait au fond que
jérôme lejeune affirme que ce soit lui
mais quand on dise discuter avec
quelqu'un qui avait été proche de de
l'histoire qui avait à peu près le même
âge que que cette histoire de la
découverte disait mais oui on sait très
bien que c'est marthe
grâce à cette découverte le chercheur
est nommé professeur de génétique en
médecine le premier en france les prix
pleuvent sur jérôme lejeune à la suite
de cette découverte en 1961 il reçoit la
médaille d'argent du cnrs puis le prix
jean toit de l'académie des sciences et
le prix de l'essec son nom est même
proposée pour le prix nobel de médecine
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là
la cause de béatification et
canonisation du serviteur de dieu jérôme
lejeune a été ouverte le 28 juin 2007 à
paris porté par l'association des amis
du professeur lejeune sa postulat triste
haute du gars est l'auteur de la
biographie dont est issu cette citation
jérôme lejeune est décédé en 1994 à
l'âge de 67 ans deux ans plus tard sont
créé une fondation et un institut de
recherche à son nom spécialisé dans
l'étude de la trisomie 21 et des
déficiences intellectuelles d'origine
génétique
c'était quelqu'un de
qui voulait et qui n'avait pas tort
monté à paris le centre le plus
important de génétique avec anomalies
chromosomiques
et il a découvert par la suite la
maladie du cri du chat hélas il était
chez lui qu'il a découvert enfin lui ou
sur l'équipe c'est une maladie où il ya
une perte une petite d'élections en
appel c'est à dire un petit perte d'un
chromosome avec un retard mental jérôme
lejeune n'est pas connue que pour son
travail sur la trisomie 21 il est aussi
connu pour un travail plus globale sur
les anomalies chromosomiques
il est aussi connu pour certaines prises
de position morale ou politique c'est
une autre affaire la fondation jérôme
lejeune est par ailleurs très engagée
politiquement
idéologiquement d'inspiration chrétienne
c'est l'une des principales associations
du mouvement pro vie en france en
croisade contre libéré l'euthanasie et
le mariage pour tous
aujourd'hui les tournures de phrases
concernant la contribution relative des
différents auteurs de la découverte de
la trisomie 21 sont généralement plus
nuancé cela fait suite à un effort de
réhabilitation tardif de marteau
gauthier épaulés par des médecins et
chercheurs
le déclic a eu lieu en 2009 ou
cinquantenaire de trisomie 21 le jeune
dix ans le grand profit le jeune est les
gens qui l'entouraient 1 qui disait que
c'était presqu'un st donc ce grand
professeur qui avait fait une découverte
extraordinaire
tout ça ça finissait quand même par
revenir très souvent toutes les semaines
pour avoir de l'argent auprès des gens
des familles etc il ya eu une sorte de
saturation parce qu'on insiste est de
plus en plus sur la lymphe hortense de
jérôme lejeune donc ça ça ça agaçait
quelques-uns quoi en réaction simone
gilles jeunes craintes invite son ami
marc gauthier a publié son témoignage
dans la revue médecine sciences
alors à partir du moment où elle a écrit
il ya eu quand même des réactions de la
part de géraud de la fondation lejeune
ça les gens étaient pas contents je
pense qu'elle le dise elle disait la
vérité il n'y a pas de problème donc il
y avait aucune raison que les gens
protestent sur elle d'autant qu'elle a
pas hélas elle a publié son témoignage
c'est tout elle a attaqué personne
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là quelques
années plus tard marthe est contacté par
le généticien alain bernheim président
de la société française de génétique
humaine
qui me dit voilà je suis président de
l'association de génétique et nous avons
tous décidé de vous donner le premier
prix de génétique étant donné les
travaux anciens que vous avez présenté
en fin d'année le prix du génétique que
nous avons même photographié tout à
l'heure et que voilà
une de ces précieux savez
la remise du prix doit avoir lieu à
bordeaux à l'occasion des assises de
génétique humaine et médicale nous
sommes en janvier 2014 marthe gauthier
88 ans doit clore ce congrès avec une
présentation sur la découverte de la
trisomie 21 mais cette conférence n'aura
pas lieu
et puis le lendemain matin à l'hôtel je
me réveillais de bonheur comme
d'habitude et on prend pas la porte de
ce qu'il y à rien ils vont vous
demandera entre montreux et qu'est ce
que c'est 118 sites justice ah bon
celui-ci justice qui me demandent à 6 et
7 heures du matin à l'hôtel où ils
savent où je suis et bon alors je
m'habille eu que des sens et je bois une
gamme a subi vous êtes ici et tu sais
pas ce que c'était que des du site us si
je vous dis et à quoi il pouvait se
passer leur temps et ils me disent bien
écouter voilà je suis le seul commandité
par la fondation lejeune comme ça là d
une longue vie derrière moi deux
publications etc j'avais jamais vu ça de
ma vie
et
on a essayé de leur dire mais pourquoi
comment etc nous voulons à cissé avoue
conférence
lui je suis pas habitué il toujours bête
comme tout va l'autre et me balance avec
un achat gauthier dit rien là une
médiatement vient de m'envoyer des
justiciers du stis la figure je ne sais
pas pourquoi et je suis
daigneault chance 4 et voilà et
l'organisateur
de la de
du congrès dit il faut pas que marthe
représente parce que moi j'ai consacré
des mois à organiser mon congrès je ne
voudrais pas que ça se termine par un
scandale
alors on est on est reparti tout les
deux les gars qui a réussi la médaille
avait prévenu les jours trois ou quatre
journalistes en disant voilà à la à
bordeaux il va y avoir un truc
intéressant la remise de la médaille
celle qui a découvert la trisomie 21 bon
donc les journalistes l'attendaient et
les journalistes attendait on leur a dit
y aura pas alors naturellement ça a fait
un boom incroyable partout en angleterre
en france
je vous états unis j'en sais rien je
crois pas mais même en angleterre ça ça
fait des publications dix ans la vraie
d'havré découvreuse de la trisomie 21
est sain
et du coup tout le monde a su qu'elle
existe
et puis bernheim me dit mais
je vous l'avais pas vu le prix de
génétique de ces panneaux puisque je
n'ai pas parlé n'est ce pas parce que
vous ai pas parlé que je n'ai pas besoin
d'écouter je verrai demain matière chez
vous le lendemain matin bernheim est
venue avec sa fille honor et il me l'a
apportée la photo est prise
donc ça s'est fait presque en catimini
avec ce garçon plus sa fille qui était
venu c'est à certains ont dû trouver que
c'était anormal et après alors ya eu des
des coups de fil de la chancellerie pour
remettre la légion d'honneur marc
gauthier jeté là oui bien sûr à la
légion d'honneur de martin gauthier est
alors maintenant elle va avoir encore
une médaille la médaille du mérite ça va
se passer dans dans quelques jours et
qui est comme il est l'étagé il lui
donne un grade supérieur elle a été
officier de la légion d'honneur or elle
va être officiers de la médaille du
mérite et du coup il faut des femmes qui
puisse lui l'a décoré mais qui est ce
grade là il y en a presque pas
la même année en septembre 2014 le
comité d'éthique de l'inserm rend son
avis concernant la contribution de
marthe gauthier dans la découverte de la
trisomie 21 nous avons cherché à
comprendre et dès le début tous les
documents où tous les témoignages dont
nous avons pu être à recueillir nous ont
montré que effectivement marc gauthier
avait joué un rôle déterminant
dans la découverte dans le contexte de
la trisomie 21 d'un chromosome
surnuméraire
à l'époque on savait pas que c'était le
21 s'était d'abord la découverte d'un
chromosome surnuméraire
le fait que marthe soit une femme at il
joué un rôle dans cette histoire dans un
article consacré à la chercheuse la
journaliste américaine anna waters écrit
une forme particulièrement maligne de
l'effet matilda s'est manifestée
récemment lorsque la scientifique
française marc gauthier a tenté une fois
de plus de gagner la reconnaissance pour
sa découverte de la cause génétique du
syndrome de donne 50 ans après les faits
les faits mathilde a nommé d'après la
militante féministe américaine du 19e
siècle matilda guedj désigne le déni ou
la minimisation systématique de la
contribution des femmes scientifiques à
la recherche
dont le travail est souvent attribuée à
leurs collègues masculins on ne peut pas
s'empêcher de
faire la remarque que marc côté est une
femme et en tirer aussi comme conclusion
que nous devons être attentifs aux
questions de genre et à faire attention
que ce ne sera pas toujours à les hommes
à qui on attribue le beau rôle on
connaît d'autres exemples découverte de
la structure de l'adn est toujours
attribué à watson creek et on oublie la
malheureuse rosalind franklin qui a
contribué de façon majeure à cette
découverte mais qui malheureusement est
décédé d'un cancer
quelques années plus tard et n'a pas pu
être reconnus par le prix nobel est
souvent omise alors qu'elle a publiée
dans nature au même moment que watson et
crick donc
nous avons cherché aussi à attirer
l'attention sur les questions du genre
dans la recherche donc voilà notre note
aller pour répondre à nos collègues sur
les événements et aussi pour tirer
quelques leçons pour nos collègues en
général sur la recherche d'elle qu'elle
se fait aujourd'hui c'est plutôt la
mémoire qui a été perdu
ça nous concerne tous voilà ça concerne
tout le milieu de la recherche c'est
pour cela que le comité d'éthique a mis
par écrit et à attirer l'attention sur
ce cette situation comme modèle parce
que ces questions là se pose en
permanence
et donc attire l'attention sur le fait
que dans les signatures d'articles faut
quand même être vigilant à respecter un
certain nombre de règles communément
admise aujourd'hui mais mal définis à
l'époque
au delà même des questions de genre ce
cas d'école illustre aussi un autre
problème dans le monde de la recherche
les conflits concernant la liste des
auteurs d'une publication qui sont
encore très fréquent aujourd'hui
à l'inserm par exemple ce motif concerne
40 % des dossiers individuels traités au
cours des dix dernières années par la
délégation à l'intégrité scientifique
on a vraiment une multiplication
malheureusement des cas de conflit sur
les hauteurs où l'heure où l'ordre des
auteurs de plus en plus de fois on voit
des gens qui sont effacées d'un article
scientifique parce que ils sont plus
entendus avec la personne responsable
de l'étude à un moment donné où ils
avaient des avis divergents sur
l'écriture du papier on voit des auteurs
qui sont ajoutés parce que ils ont une
certaine influence
ou au niveau du journal ou au niveau de
l'obtention de certains crédits on voit
des contestations sur l'ordre des
auteurs et ça c'est souvent le fait de
doctorants ou de post doctorants qui
trouvent que ils se sont beaucoup
investis et qui sont pas assez reconnus
ou c'est parfois des collaborations dans
laquelle
les conditions de la collaboration ont
pas été bien préciser au départ et où un
des auteurs pensent qui va être qu'au
dernier auteur dans la collaboration et
puis il est mis juste comme
collaborateur est pas comme qu'au
dernier c'est aussi la perversité d'un
système où certains instituts ou
certaines commissions
n'attribue de valeur
signature d'un article que si on est
premiers dernier où corresponding et du
coup
cette tendance amène à des
l'augmentation de la fréquence des
conflits parce que
du coup pour les évaluations que ce soit
les évaluations de carrière ou les
évolutions pour obtenir des crédits
cette place dans l'ordre l'ordre des
auteurs dans un papier où l'attribution
du rôle de dernier ou de corresponding
devient importante devient fort impact
pour
la possibilité de poursuivre sa carrière
ou poursuivre ses recherches et son
financement
ces manquements à l'éthique qui sont
donc encouragés par le système même de
fonctionnement de la recherche
scientifique qui encourage les
chercheurs a publié à outrance ce qu'ils
ont surnommé le publish or perish
publier ou périr
il faudra un jour qu'on attribue moins
d'importance à l'ordre mais plus
d'importance à la contribution réelle de
chacun moins d'importance à la quantité
plus d'importance à la qualité et ça ça
veut dire s'abstraire de la métrique un
peu bête de l'impact facteurs au dos ou
d'autres éléments comme si le système
était moins aboutie et moins encadrée à
l'époque une époque où les femmes
avaient du mal à accéder aux études
supérieures faut se remettre dans le
contexte de l'époque on était en 1959
déjà qu'une femme fasse médecine c'était
absolument pas ordinaires qu'une femme
réussissent une pareille découverte
c'était encore moins admissible pour les
hommes donc c'était c'était très
compliqué mais ce qu'il ya de
particulier dans l'histoire de marthe
c'est que on peut presque parler d'une
d'une pérennité de la justice puisque ça
fait 60 ans maintenant en janvier de
cette année ça fait soixante ans que
cette femme a été dépossédée de sa
découverte je crois qu'aujourd'hui tout
le monde convient en convient la justice
ait démontré la question que pose le
livre et à laquelle évidemment je ne
réponds pas assez à chaque lecteur d'y
répondre c est ce qu au delà de la
justice il ya une imposture
marque prend la chose avec philosophie
comme en témoigne l'écrivain corinne
royer autrice du roman ce qui nous
revient dans lequel elle croise une
histoire fictionnel avec celle de marc
gauthier l'auteur s'est donc entretenu
plusieurs fois avec marthe pour préparer
son roman le particularisme de marthe
c'est quand même cette curiosité
viscéral au monde etc etc cette
curiosité qui a fait qu'elle a pu
réussir c'est de cette découverte c'est
cette ce côté intuitif
c'est cette volonté de tout savoir sur
tout et elle a toujours ce regard plein
d'optimisme sur le monde le livre c'est
plutôt une façon d'être avec plutôt
qu'une charge contre et si le livre est
comme ça c'est parce que effectivement
il colle à l'état d'esprit de marthe qui
jamais dans tous nos entretiens dans
tous nos échanges n'a jamais eu de
propos extrêmement virulent qui
effectivement a fait une brillante
carrière scientifique dans les suites du
vol de cette découverte est donc oui je
crois que c'est pour moi ça a été
vraiment une leçon de résilience quoi
cette femme est vraiment un exemple
magnifique de résilience et pendant nos
entretiens il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
joie
[Musique]
il aura fallu quelques 50 ans et
beaucoup d'efforts pour rendre à marc
gauthier la découverte dont elle avait
été dépossédé une découverte réalisée au
début d'une carrière brillante dans le
laboratoire du professeur turpin à
l'hôpital trousseau à paris grâce à son
propre sérum du plasma de coke un
savoir-faire importé des états unis et
de la verrerie acheter sur ses propres
deniers la voilà qui réalise une avancée
scientifique qui restera dans l'histoire
[Musique]
et je me souviens d'un jour où je suis
allée chez elle dans son bordel
et il y avait une tableau avec des
chromosomes alors je lui dis tiens vous
avez mis des chromosomes sur votre mur
madiba oui ça s'oublie quand même pas
mais elle était déjà cardiologue depuis
depuis cardio pédiatre depuis longtemps
elle n'avait pas oublier bien sûr son
histoire c'est l'oeuvre de ma vie qui
restera mais je dois dire que soigner
les enfants cardiaques chez quelque
chose
quelque chose peut pas oublier
publié trois chromosomes mais pas ça
[Musique]
il y
mais
[Musique]